puis en résistant à la volée avec moi tu
vois avec moi tu devrais tu auras tu
viens avec moi va tout s'en va
[Musique]
je raconte tout investissement ça dans
mon oreillette comme c'est en régie
influence sebaoun voilà qui fait
n'importe quoi à quelques danses et
voilà donc je les aime beaucoup mais bon
ce moment allait surtout les mecs elle
est partie à ibiza la semaine dernière
s'est mis à l'abri avec les animations
c'est mykonos la semaine prochaine
elle a laissé en fait l'oreillette
branché donc j'entends comme un bon
voilà tout le truc je dois j'ai
l'impression qu'à nicolas hulot qui sont
dans mon oreille voilà merci mais
personne ne fait rien résolu à la merci
c'est ça la france
retour en terre inconnue qui était très
long chez vous n'étiez pas fan de cette
émission je suis un petit peu le voilà
je sais que vous et gilles verdez vous
êtes un petit peu énervé par un retour
en terre inconnue on va en parler tout
de suite c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gars est-ce que vous avez vu des
jingle si pas plus longtemps après
derrière mayence a fait cinq minutes que
j'ai dit jingle bells qu'est ce qu'il a
dit des choses
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent y portent l on
est tranquille nos trains de fumée des
pets quoi ça le job qu'on envoie détruit
quoi ça m'a fait des tours alors on
régis vous m'écoutez pas parce que vous
n'arrêtez pas en fait un merci bah si
c'est pas toi non parce que l'affluence
0,10 mais c'est pas moi c'est dur pour
moi c'est toi
voilà pour moi c'est toi et du président
avec moi tu dois beaucoup
souvent de clients un support des 3
jeudi à des cures a tu viens avec moi va
tout s'en va
ça va pas non plus de faire des prêts
mais qu'est-ce que jordan qui comment ça
se fait que ça s'ouvre dans mon oreille
je veux des responsables déjà il ya un
gars là il a encore des oeufs de pâques
dans ses cheveux tardé à baisser ou
alors qui s'en occupe c'est qui je veux
c'est ckoi asselah c'est là bas on va
rire je vais tout vous montrer les gars
saoul de magal justin bieber c'est toi
qui es en train de mettre des trucs dans
mon oreille mais non non ça c'est qui
c'est qui c'est justin c'est justin
bieber c'est un fond de jeu style et
justin bieber et jetez moi alors il ya
même un gardien pour le son au fait ça
va alors c'est d'ici c'est d'ici que ne
partent pas tous les sous ne touche pas
à mon poste
voilà vous savez des sons qui parquent
baba 6e c'est toi le responsable ouais
vous aiguiller le sourire la fille
d'accord et pourquoi t'as pas puis pour
le son oui pourquoi pas du sang tu veux
quoi
basi alors voix a trouvé que la vie à
plus de 27
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
pas mal en année je vais appuyer sur le
jeu va payer sur le allez voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu sois là que des musiques de merde en
fait à merde non merde c'est david
guetta revient demain c'est vachement
bien parce que j'entends pas dit si en
fait je me fous dans la mer de toi je me
fous la merde je te le dis merci en tout
cas c'est super sympa votre merci et
vous savez que j'ai toujours le bordel
mots dans l'oreille d'accord merci salut
les gars
[Musique]